[موسيقى]
يمكن أن تكون العملات المشفرة للذكاء الاصطناعي في
blockchain صعبة الفهم
ولكن هذه الكلمات الطنانة جمعت
الآلاف من عشاق التشفير في دبي ،
وكان مارسيلو ماري أحدهم يعتقد أن
الجمع بين الذكاء الاصطناعي
في blockchain سيحدث ثورة في
قطاع الخدمات المالية.
إضفاء الطابع الديمقراطي على
الوصول إلى هذه التكنولوجيا القوية بشكل لا يصدق ،
إنها فكرة كبيرة من المحتمل أن توفر
للشركات المالية ما يصل إلى 12 مليار
دولار سنويًا ،
لذا ما هو بالضبط blockchain AI
إذا كنت سأطلب من أي شخص عن هذه
التقنيات ، سيكون
عالم التكنولوجيا الأستاذ سكوت ستورنيتا
أصدقائي  اتصل بي صاحب الجلالة
لتسجيل أن الشيء الجلالة الخاص بك كان
مزاحًا تمامًا
لكنه معروف عمومًا باسم الأب الروحي
لـ blockchain ،
شعرنا أنه يمكن أن يكون
قوة
تسوية كبيرة ، فإن
blockchain هو في الأساس سلسلة من
أجزاء صغيرة من المعلومات تسمى block
المخزنة على خوادم مختلفة
يقول الخبراء هؤلاء  تعمل الكتل الصغيرة على تحسين
أمان الشفافية وإمكانية تتبع المعاملات الرقمية ،
لذا فإن كيفية تناسب الذكاء الاصطناعي مع كل هذا الذكاء الاصطناعي
هو الذكاء الشبيه بالبشر الذي تستخدمه
الآلات لأتمتة
حل المشكلات وتحليل
البيانات مع توحيد جميع البيانات بسبب
استخدام blockchain لعمل  إنها
قابلة للتشغيل البيني ،
إنها تمامًا مثل وليمة
الذكاء الاصطناعي ، لدينا
blockchain يخزن محيطًا من المعلومات والذكاء الاصطناعي
الذي يختار
فقط القطرات اللازمة لاتخاذ
قرارات مستنيرة بناءً على هذا المحيط
من مجموعات البيانات الضخمة التي تحتوي على أكثر من 10000
عملة مشفرة في
السوق.  يصعب على
أي شخص اتخاذ قرارات
مستنيرة من خلال الجمع بين blockchain و ai للتنبؤ
بأداء العملة المشفرة
إذا تم تعيين الأسعار على الانخفاض ،
ستنصح شركة marchello العملاء بالبيع أو
الشراء إذا كان من المتوقع أن يرتفع
المستخدم العادي يمكنه فقط شراء
رمز Dynastar
وهذا هو  ليس هناك الكثير مما
يحتاجون إلى القيام
به وسيقوم الذكاء الاصطناعي بعمل كل شيء
تلقائيًا
يبدو هذا رائعًا الآن ، لكن
النقاد يقولون إن هذه التقنية لا تزال
تتطور وقد تستغرق سنوات لإحداث تأثير حقيقي ،
لكن مع استمرار الشركات في
تجربة
الأعمال التجارية لن تقرر بين ذكاء اصطناعي
أو
بلوكتشين بل مزيجًا من
كيم كيلتا سي إن إن دبي